chases her down and murders her with an
axe she wants to keep what she's got
with Howard and mity knows too much
thanks to their little role-play
exercise in order to continue thriving
in Her Fantasy she chops up mity and
feeds her to Theta the luckiest Gator on
Earth probably then sets the table for a
lovely magot infested porch Pig dinner
with her parents corpses her complete
mental breakdown could not have come at
a better time for her husband who had
just been discharged from the war and
was on his way home to discover this
horrific scene when he arrives Pearl
does her best to play at cool but fails
miserable her loneliness after after
Howard went to fight in the war was the
main catalyst that drove her over the
edge and his unexpected return
essentially broke her brain